joining us now with his take on Joe
Biden a much more ESPN host Stephen A
Smith I read somewhere that your ratings
man what's up man uh my my old friend I
read somewhere that your show is just
crushing your competitors show who you
used to be friends with and partners
with is there any truth to that or is
that a lie is that the media mob line
well uh well the media mob is not lying
I'm not going to classify it is that I
respect my former colleagues kid Bayless
and all my points that are there with my
brothers well you said you hope you
continue to Pummel him that you said you
were there on the other side excuse me
excuse me sir yes I mean the bottom line
is I'm competing I'm competing okay and
the fact is if you go against if you go
against me I'm trying to win all the
time you notice about me showing
anything you've known me for years okay
good luck with that and by the way
you're looking good the hair cutter you
got a nice haircut for a change
congratulations it's the same haircut
I've had for 27 going on 28 years thanks
a lot all right let me let me go to this
issue all right so you're not a trump
guy you're not a Biden guy and you're a
Gavin Newsome guy yeah okay well that's
true
well listen here's the truth here's the
truth okay when I talk about Biden what
I said was in the class and and clarify
my statement because I saw how you led
with it or whatever I'm no fan of trump
and because of how he conducts himself
I've told you that I'm even getting the
policies how he conduct himself he's
like a petulant child I can't stand it
okay you need statesmanship in that
position but in the case of Biden
clearly he doesn't seem to be as cogent
and as Lucid as we would like him to be
my bigger point was this it is a
disgrace for the Democratic party to
call themselves progressives when
they're virtually begging an 82 year old
man at election time to run for
reelection that is the point that I was
making you're supposed to be Progressive
right supposed to be moving forward
supposed to be thinking forward you're
supposed to be being Innovative and
younger and all of this other stuff and
you're leaning on the hopes and the
prayers of an 82 year old who would be
Joe bodies 80 right now Ba's on 81 he'll
be 82 at the time a re-election if that
would have happened to depend on him is
an indictment against the Democratic
party and the reason I brought up Gavin
Newsom is because listen I am absolutely
positively allergic to the high taxes in
California I can't stand them to me the
state invents ways to take your money
it's just unbelievable to me but to
watch him
sit directly face to face with you
showing Hannity and go Toe to Toe the
way that y'all did it was I'm going to
give you credit what credits do because
it's red as you deserve it you know I
love you it's rare that you deserve
credit for what I'm about to say to sit
up there and to have you do an interview
sitting directly across from somebody
that is opposite of you in terms of
ideology you actually gave him
opportunities to speak and to explain
himself I thought that he was as
articulate and as forceful and as
powerful as any Democrat out there and
even you admitted that as you sat across
from him
I couldn't get him to admit which is
obvious and that is every day his phone
is pinging day and night morning noon
and night
I remember that listen respectfully
personally because respectfully that I
thought that was a silly question on
your part what's he supposed to do so he
told you he was he's in he's in a in the
motorcade with President Trump he told
president about it he told you he's been
at the White House he told you he
communicates with him constantly then
he's supposed to go and show ahead of
these show and say you know what you
know what people are calling me all the
time
you know better than that because you
and I both know you and I wait a minute
you and I both know that is absolutely a
thousand percent true now the problem
look hold on hold on no no no no hold on
it's true it's true but you but it's
absolutely true but you I know this from
Sean Hannity every truth they made to be
told now you don't have to lie but you
ain't telling every truth why would he
admit that on National Television of
course
not true you can't expect them to do
that you sound like Biden oh man you
know I know I don't you know better than
that I would not do that I found a lot
better boy you're running as far away
from him as you can get all right talk
about taxes all right and I I like Evan
and he's going to debate Rhonda Santos
on this show which I'm looking forward
to the question is you know when you
look at the taxes the highest in the
country when you look at for the first
time he's the only Governor that had a
net loss of population people are
flocking out of that state because the
burdensome regulation and Taxation you
know you pay a dollar more than the
national average
I want to answer this okay I'll put them
up on the screen so my audience can see
all true thank you
what I'm saying to you however is this
somebody named Sean Hannity my buddy for
nearly two decades now who I've known
very well said to me you can't judge
somebody in the immediacy of the moment
the prism of History has to do it you've
said that to me many times I
regurgitated that comment from you many
many times we know about Kobe we know
about the trillions of dollars that have
been spent from the previous
administration as law as well as this
one they're all guilty of it the great
one himself Mark Levin has acknowledged
that nobody's nobody's absolved from
being from the spending that has taken
place over the last several days
I'm putting up all the statistics
Florida versus you know California
that's why I think this debating you
can't do that when you have to do
something I did so I handed them every
single one of these charts that I'm
putting up right now
watch it later okay okay
one policy that he's implemented that
you say wow that was a great policy and
that's helped the state of California
I'm not qualified to make that statement
because the reality of the situation is
when I look at Biden I've got a lot of
question mark Sodom I'm not going to shy
away from that I'm big on immigration
I'm big on National Security I'm big on
the economy and there are question marks
with him Ad nauseam there's no doubt
about that but if you are slippery
you can't cite a single thing that you
would point to and say wow we need to
duplicate that nationally
production
I mean it's more complicated than that I
wouldn't say no definitively it depends
on how safe it is for the American Pie
as of today I don't know the answers
literally tell you what you want me to
do
all right coming up all right good to
see you hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else